Heroes so my my point is that if you are
the leader and you're responsible for
somebody you have to make the best
decisions and even if the decision makes
them upset you have to do what makes
them healthy and in the long run so
that's my personal opinion on these
things
do you think that polygamy could be a
solution going forward yeah no because
polygamy would destabilize society and
this is what blows my mind about the red
pill and the red pill some of the red
pill guys always talking about how a
high value management exercises options
imagining that's how you know that's how
I started was because my dad didn't like
that like in that category and I called
him I'm like Dad where are your hoes
you're supposed to have some oh Lord
Jesus I was I was so confused I was like
I didn't grow up with that like this
listen listen this is a different world
yeah you got to do a lot of when they're
explaining I was like wow this is very
different you took and drank the
Kool-Aid you're fully in it but
hopefully by the end of today's you know
you realize I don't I don't first like I
don't agree with cheating I've never
said I agreed with cheating I just said
you drink the Kool-Aid no no no no no
isn't that doesn't that mean like then
then like I'm a part doesn't that mean
that then I have a different opinion on
it I thought that's what that meant when
you said you drank the Kool-Aid what I'm
saying is that there's certain
ideologies and beliefs that you have
that I I when you when I hear you say
them I'm like thing I I remember that
video where somebody uttered that idea
and I'm like man did she copy and pastes
or does she genuinely believe it and so
going back to the point well I just I
it makes sense to me if someone has a
good argument like why would I not
if I've researched it and I think it's a
good argument you've just seen some of
the things you haven't researched
so my my rule of thumb is the definition
of apraxiality 100 okay okay 100 because
you you call me yellow and you said it's
not an ideology it's a practiology let
me know what that word even means off
the top of my head no you're right I
just had a general idea okay cool okay
so in regards you asked me about
polygamy it destabilizes Society here's
why think about a guy like an Andrew
Tate Andrew Tate is tall he's handsome
and successful if Andrew Tate was like I
want everybody's girl he can Genghis
Khan this whole planet he could yeah
Genghis Khan this whole planet like
Genghis Khan dead and here's the reality
for the average guy it doesn't benefit
him because if you even if you've seen
freaking um Braveheart right obviously
it's a fictional movie but this is an
example with Prima noctic going on in
Scotland there was a time of the day
wherever dude wanted your woman they
pull up and then take your woman what
are you gonna do about it I'm in charge
and so I've never seen Braveheart but
you're missing out on 2.5 in your life
it's a movie 2.5 of your life is missing
you haven't watched Braveheart my point
of it and this is why like I had so much
respect from when Andrew Tate was
talking about male promiscuity wasn't a
good thing because as a guy if you want
if if guys wanted to take all they could
play that Genghis Khan game and that
would disrupt society and you think men
today are complaining about one-third of
men don't have sex and all the Chads and
Tyrone's are having sex and not me let
polygamy be normal let the game let them
let them let the flood waters really
really let free and so to me I truly
believe that destabilizer society and
they create an equal opportunity for all
men we have to be able to say no one man
one woman what do you think if it was
like they could have multiple but it
would be like capped you're like don't
sound really Islam is almost up to four
yeah I was just wondering if you thought
that was like would you would you feel
the same way because wouldn't it be it
would be like polygamy but it wouldn't
be like on stair like no Genghis Khan's
out here yeah yeah so so that's that
that's Islam's argument right is Islamic
community's arguments that but it also
destabilizes Society because think about
it right now yeah you're a numbers girl
like I said you're smarter than me yeah
let's say we had a hundred women and
there was 99 men let's say 99 men in
society right 100 women 99 men how can
every man get four wives how many wives
how many men can you get four watches
you know what I mean So So eventually
that's kind of what it is now though and
you and you told me that's the problem
yeah you're right and that's why I'm so
passionate I'm like yo you if you truly
believe the problem in today's world is
promiscuity is a few women going to all
the chats and Tyrone how can you ascribe
to this High Valley exercise option to
be able to have multiple women
yeah
like when you when you say you like I
think you're talking about me because
it's me and you no so like if I say you
like I would think that you know I'm
sorry I'm talking yeah okay okay
so so that's what I'm trying to
communicate yeah and so at the end of
the day I realize that if you're trying
to really help Society one man can't
have 10 15 20 girls it's not gonna help
us yeah it's not gonna help it average
dude in Indiana it's not fair so in my
dad when I when I told my dad that he
was like yeah have these guys try one
wife before they drive and let's talk
about it so to me my number one my my
second pushback one of my many 75
pushbacks in the red pill ID is like if
you've had one wife having three to me
is like torture I'm being honest with
you not saying my one wife is I'm saying
having three because those three are
competing for your time energy and
attention I come my name is Hafiz I my
office is not an African name ignorant
people it's not a Nigerian name sadly
educated people is an Arabic name my
family's all Arabic uh most of every
male in my family my dad's side of the
family is Muslim I come from a
polygamous background the reality of the
matter is polygamous families have
issues they have issues not freaking
Bliss what issues are they because I
don't know anyone that personally like
grew up with that so I'm just curious
Give an example you have women like you
okay you're the smart wife you're
intelligent you're submissive you do
everything the right way you're
attractive everything is great the six
other than the husband says I want to
spend more time with you I wanna I want
your kids to go to the best schools I
want your kids every night so it's like
favorites other women gonna feel about
you they're gonna hate does it does it
come and go because I'd imagine like
there'd be Seasons because everyone's
got pros and cons or does does he
usually have a one favorite that's like
always the favorite you can't have 10
women I have one favorite yeah well I'm
just thinking like in a friend group
like I'll have one favorite but then you
know she might annoy me and then like
that'll switch you know but you but you
deep down inside no there's a friend
that you naturally get along with more
than everybody else it may be seasonal
when you get along with somebody else
but over the long span of a friendship I
I naturally gravitate towards it so it's
kind of like there's like jealousy that
builds up because he doesn't what's the
most wives one of your like I said it's
not I can't talk on behalf of my family
because my dad doesn't want me talking
about these things publicly okay um but
you know what's the most wives you've
seen are like personally people don't so
um in Nigeria I'm Nigerian there's three
major tribes yes
most night dream that you meet in the
western world are Yoruba and Evo I've
met IBO you rarely meet hausa you will
never they stay in Nigeria houses are
predominantly Muslims those guys 20 25
30 like those they will keep on taking
and keep on taking but some of them be
like the religion holds them back but
you gotta think about it the religion
capsum at four but how many people
really follow their religion all the way
you know what I mean like Christianity
Christianity said you shouldn't have sex
until marriage
okay because I know live in London and
so like there's a lot of I I've had so
many Nigerians on my I feel like
Nigerian people just really like to
share their opinions but I don't know
why this is our culture especially
evil I don't I don't understand the
tribes I don't know the background this
is just I've had so many evotes
on my show and they're all yeah but
um yeah actually I forgot where I was
going you were saying that the Nigeria I
was making a point about having multiple
wives
the Nigerian uncle they always say like
like be careful of the Nigerian Uncle
because it's in London because what'll
happen is they're like he'll spoil like
this is they said it like because I've
heard them reference this and I do this
mysterious Nigerian uncle that Hill
he'll spoil you and whatever but he has
a whole family 100 that's what they do
that's what they do yeah the unfortunate
part of the coach of the polygamist
culture so yeah to the original question
yeah you stabilize the society and
that's why I'm just like if you're
really trying to help men you know that
you need to you need to tell hey man you
guys need one it's then so the other
guys can have more think about like you
said you want to incentivize women
incentivize what you want to see more if
the women really realize that hey you're
not going to beat so-and-so side chick
you're not going to be so-and-so's
fourth and fifth wife you're gonna have
to lower your standards yeah it will
change them like you said it will change
them but if every woman knows you know I
can be I can be Futures number 17. I can
be so number 15. like then it's going to
continue to create this issues that
we're having in today's world yeah it's
just like my thing is as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible